You have another nightmare?
Yeah.
Are you actually happy with how your life has turned out?
Why the hell shouldn't I be?
What do you know about this Rekall place?
Stay away from them.
They mess with your mind, man.
Welcome to Rekall.
First time?
Tell us your fantasy, we'll give you the memory.
You wanna be the crime fighter,...
...or world-class athlete.
Or secret agent.
Yeah.
Happy trails, man.
What is it? What's wrong?
Yank that needle off before it ticks!
Why are you here? Why?
Police!
Oh, whoa! Wait, wait, wait!
This is all a mistake. I'm a nobody.
Hands on your head, now!
Oh my god!
Why are you trying to kill me?
Your memory was erased.
Your mind was implanted with the life you think you've lived.
Oh, by the way, you haven't even begun to see me trying to kill you.
Get in.
I've been looking for you everywhere.
If I'm not me, then who the hell am I?
You don't have the most reliable of memories, do you?